[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARIA DE LA FUENTE: Today, we
would like to introduce Javid.
So in behalf of Google
and all of the Googlers,
welcome to Google.
DR. JAVID ABDELMONEIM:
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: Hi, there.
DR. JAVID ABDELMONEIM: Hello.
Hello.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
So, Javid, just
so you know, we're
expecting something like this.
Do you have instruments,
or a band, or what--
DR. JAVID ABDELMONEIM:
That's sitting at the back.
The rest of the team is there.
SPEAKER 1: I'm kidding.
So I'm sure no one's is
here to hear about me,
but I'm just going to briefly
introduce you to everyone.
And I'll pass the mic.
So Javid is probably
one of the people we
need to hear more of at Google.
He's been working in
Doctors Without Borders
for a very long time.
And he's worked in a
lot of crisis regions,
like the Ebola crisis in Sierra
Leone, like refugees in Athens.
He's also worked around
the regions as well.
So I'm sure we can learn
a lot from what he does.
So I think the best
way in these talks
is to make it a very
organic, very open thing.
So we'll have Javid talk
for about 20, 25 minutes,
but your feedback is great.
I think he also is
very curious to know
what you guys think about their
operations and what they do.
So I think we'll be able to
have a very nice discussion
together.
So thank you, guys.
And off to Javid.
DR. JAVID ABDELMONEIM:
Thank you, [? Majid. ?]
Thanks very much, everybody.
Thank you for having
me and MSF here
for what is your inaugural
Google talk here in Dubai.
So I think that's fantastic.
I'm going to give
you an idea of what
it's like to work on the
frontline in MSF as a doctor.
I'm a doctor myself.
And also to give you a chance
to ask questions to clear up
any ideas you might have.
So what I'm going to do over
the next almost 40 minutes,
actually-- so
sorry to shock you;
I'll try and keep it down--
is give you a picture
of what I first
did with MSF, Medecins
Sans Frontieres,
and what I last did.
And they tie in somehow.
But interestingly,
I found out today
that one of your Google
mottoes is don't be evil.
Is that right?
And of course, the first
medical ethic is do no harm.
I don't know if you knew that.
So that's a really nice
link between Google
and Medecins Sans Frontieres,
Doctors Without Borders.
We're a medical organization.
And medical ethics are a
core value of who we are.
And who am I anyway?
So I'm an emergency physician.
I work in hospital in London.
But I also go to
the field with MSF.
I'm now on the board of MSF UK.
We manage ourselves.
We can be the governors
of the charities.
And this is a picture of
me on the ship Aquarius,
taken last summer, about
which I'll talk later.
I actually pointed here.
Just to really map out--
the founding
principles of MSF are
what you see there--
independence, neutrality,
and impartiality.
The independence comes from
the funding stream, essentially
being literal public,
and also the fact
that we govern ourselves.
So people like me who
have been in the field,
we can put ourselves
forward for elections
internally to manage
the charity, which
is what I do currently.
Impartiality is a medical
thing, essentially.
It's the fact that a human
being in front of you,
no matter what
their religion is,
or no matter where they're from,
how they got ill or injured,
they're your patient.
And a patient is a patient, and
you're the health care giver.
So you don't ask questions
about your patient.
That's what impartiality is.
So my first experience with MSF,
I was one year in the field.
I was six months in Iraq.
And while I was in Iraq, there
was the Haitian earthquake,
which was right at the
beginning of January 2010.
And in fact, Haiti
was the first time
Google got together with MSF.
You helped with some mapping
of the disease of cholera
when it struck the country later
in the year, in October time.
And I'll come on to a little
bit of the cholera experience
there.
But this was a difficult
experience for me.
I had gone there to work
in this hospital here.
So just look-- oh, wrong button.
Does the pointer-- can
you see the pointer?
This was the medical
tent just here--
32 inpatient beds.
So I was there to run the
internal medicine department
that you see there.
The emergency room, which
is just behind it, and also
the Intensive Care Unit.
But obviously, the
standard of care
after an earthquake
in that setting
are not as high as
you might expect.
So it was really
quite challenging.
I was seeing a lot of
infectious diseases, typhoid,
malaria particularly,
tuberculosis, HIV,
which I had no means to
treat, lots of violence,
lots of interpersonal
violence, and a lot
of non-communicable diseases,
so asthma, diabetes, strokes,
heart attacks.
So a really wide variety of
caseload but in very difficult
circumstances.
So despite my having
arrived in Haiti in June--
I left Iraq in--
I took a month break.
I arrived in Haiti at
the beginning of June,
which was already six
months after the earthquake.
But it still looked like this.
These are all my pictures.
I keep pressing
the wrong button.
Every building, everywhere,
some form of destruction.
You can't imagine.
Every horizon just
rubble and destruction.
But people trying to
get on with their day.
Here are two boys--
if the pointer works.
You can see two
boys there walking
past this building
going to school.
This picture on the
bottom left is just tents.
People were living in tents.
I didn't go anywhere special
to take this picture.
Every sidewalk, every pavement.
You drive to work,
this is what you see.
Or if they had managed to
get together some money
to build some proper shelters--
proper in terms of
a bit more solid--
you can see there in the bottom
right some corrugated tin
because the hurricane season
comes on later in the year.
It's imperative to try and get
a little bit more fixed shelter.
But what this paints a
picture is that there
was no water and sanitation.
Very hot, very
cramped conditions.
On a background of
where we were working,
which is a place called City of
Soleil, which meant Sun City.
It's the favela, so to speak,
the slum of the capital.
And here is our convoy
arriving through the gates
of the hospital.
The UN wouldn't
even go in there.
There was no safety
for anyone, but MSF
in such a place because
of the gang warfare
that was rife there.
But we-- because we
gave free health care
and had been there for many
years-- had free access.
So it was-- there was
a lot of violence.
There was a lot of gun crime
and a lot of sexual violence
that I was treating
in my emergency room.
So it was difficult.
And as you can see there,
that picture in the tent,
this is one of the doctors.
You can see how
cramped the beds are.
But what we're doing here
is those top two pictures
are taken on the same day that
Hurricane Thomas was coming in.
At this point, the
cholera had struck
in the north of the
country already,
but it hadn't
arrived in the city.
But November 4, we were just
packing up the hospital.
We had to vacate the
lower ground floor.
My medical tent
had to pack it up.
There was no way that would
have survived a hurricane.
Had to move all the patients.
Either discharge
them or move them up
into the hospital first floor.
So that's the picture inside the
tent with most of the patients
having gone.
And just four of us
there in the team,
one of the nurses,
the logistician,
and the medical team
leader, and myself,
did an extra hurricane
night shift in case
it should strike the
hospital and there were
any emergencies at that time.
So we stayed in the
hospital overnight.
But actually, the
hurricane swerved
north at the last
minute and really missed
hitting the city firmly.
But nonetheless, there was
a big storm, lots of water.
And cholera is water-borne.
It's spread through water.
And it gives you symptoms
of a very profuse diarrhea
and vomiting.
And the very next
day, it essentially
washed into the city
with Hurricane Thomas
and into the slum.
And I had just finished
that night shift.
I was just walking out.
And there was a trauma case.
A man had been hacked by a group
of vigilantes and attacked.
And he had been
accused, so to speak,
of stealing a purse from
a woman in the area.
And we weren't able to save him.
He was hacked to death.
My clothes were absolutely
covered in blood.
But luckily, because I had
spent the night in the hospital,
I had an extra bag.
And I changed my clothes.
And on the way out to
go to the car park,
we had situated a
pre-triage area.
You don't want any
patient with cholera
to be able to
enter the hospital.
It's highly infectious.
And we had pediatrics
and obstetrics.
We needed to keep all these
vulnerable patients separate
from the cholera patients.
And I went into the tent.
And the nurses said, I think
we've got our first cases.
And it was three children
and some parents.
And indeed, they
were cholera cases.
And the next day, we had 16.
And the next day, we had
something in the mid 20s.
And by the end of
the week, we were
approaching 200 cases a day.
And it was something
that you just no
matter how you think
you may be prepared--
and it was my first time in such
a field-- there was something
very, very hard to manage.
Patients, when they're
sick with cholera--
this picture on
the top left there,
you can see there
are holes in the bed.
There's a hole in the bed.
Yeah?
So under that hole is a bucket.
And at the top end is a bucket.
The patients get so
debilitated that you just
do it in your bed.
And your job is to wash them
and to get rid of the buckets
and fill it with chlorine,
because chlorine neutralizes
the cholera toxin.
And we were building beds.
We'd run out of beds.
And you put two, three
children down on a bed just
to find space.
And people were coming--
it's such a violent
part of the city
that people wouldn't
come overnight.
It's so dangerous to
be outdoors overnight.
So there'd be a lull.
There'd be a lull overnight.
And we were doing our
day shift in the hospital
and volunteering to do
extra shifts in the evening
until the emergency pool
came to bolster our services.
So overnight, you would do
little logistical things.
The huge buckets at the top
left of that top left picture,
they're about 200 liters of
oral rehydration solution, which
is if you're only a moderate
case, you just need to top up.
The management of cholera
is to avoid dehydration.
It's as simple as that.
It'll self limit up until then,
essentially, give or take.
But patients lose
so much fluids.
If they're very, very severe--
you can see these
bags of fluids here.
Each one is one liter.
The normal human
need is 2.7, call it
three, liters in a day without
extra losses, so three liters,
24 hours.
A severe case of cholera
may need five, six, seven
liters in the first two hours.
You die in two hours by
vomiting and diarrheaing
your entire body fluids out.
It's severe when it's severe.
And it's really, really not fun.
I remember one night,
a different night,
this oral rehydration
salt buckets had run out.
Because if you're
a moderate case
and you're not vomiting
too much, you can drink.
And that's the best way
to get fluids into you.
But those buckets had run out.
It was raining.
It was about 3:00
in the morning.
You've had a long day.
It's like, oh, my god, why the
hell have these buckets run out
right now?
And there wasn't any of the
ready made solution left.
You're chasing your tail.
Logistics couldn't keep up.
You're building beds.
Patients are down.
ORS has run out.
Make some.
So I had to tear each
sachet, 200 sachets, of--
I'll put this down.
I'm not managing to point--
of oral rehydration
salts into this buckets
and then fill it up in the rain.
And you're just having
one of these moments
in your life when you
think to yourself,
how have I ended up
in this situation
where it's 3:00 in the
morning, it's raining,
people are all around me,
sometimes you hear gunshots
left, right, and center.
And it's just-- so I had one
of those moments where you just
question what path you've
taken in your life.
And I thought, right,
I'm going to go
to bed for a couple of hours.
But before I went to bed,
I saw two of the cases
were really quite on the
borderline of switching
from those oral fluids,
the bucket drinking,
to the intravenous fluids.
So I told the team members,
guys, keep an eye on those two.
They were young girls, actually.
Keep an eye on those two.
I'm going to go for
a couple of sleep.
Have a low index of suspicion
for switching to intravenous.
And I came back,
and they were dead.
And exactly-- gasp, sigh.
And what can-- well,
I blamed myself.
What can you do?
And you just think
to yourself, my god,
I should have just put
that cannula in myself,
and the children
would be alive today.
So it's a difficult--
it's a difficult
thing to deal with.
I'm quite all or
nothing in that way.
You are success or fail,
no gray in between.
And I ended up fixing
on this negative moment.
And it's quite hard,
because you have to stuff
the orifices of
a human when they
die with cholera with
cotton soaked bleach,
because things ooze out
and become infectious.
And so I had to hand back
this young girl to her mother
in the morning.
And you're blaming yourself.
And she's looking at you and
saying thanks for trying.
So this was an awful moment
for me, particularly,
which I haven't talked about.
This is only the third time I've
talked about this since 2010.
But it was a circumstance--
the first time
I had seen there was no dignity
for patients whatsoever.
This is a cattle truck.
This is how we had to
transport patients.
This lady was actually pregnant.
You sit them on
buckets to move them
from a triage area to the actual
main cholera treatment center
that we built in a football
pitch down the road.
There was no dignity.
And there was fear
in the community.
There hadn't been cholera
for centuries in Haiti.
And so when we were first
doing transfers during the day,
they were throwing
rocks, burning tires.
So we had to do it overnight.
And again, you have these night
shifts where it's raining,
and you're pushing patients
like this into a truck,
covering the truck
with plastic sheeting
so no one can see what's
inside, and moving them
across the city.
It's not a dignified--
it's not dignified.
It's inhumane.
But needs must.
It was what we had to
do to just try and get
anything done for these people.
It was a very
difficult situation.
But that was the last month
of my six months there.
And if I would ever
characterize the first five
months of being just a low
grade assault on my psyche.
I wanted to be able
to treat strokes,
but we didn't have
the medication.
I wanted to be able to
treat heart attacks,
but there was no
coronary care unit.
I wanted to be able to treat
these men with tuberculosis,
but there were no other actors.
It's an earthquake.
So you can't.
But when you're faced with these
patients, and you just say,
I know what you have.
I know what I want to
do for you, but I can't.
This is what's going
to happen to you
over the next few months--
a death sentence in
a few of the cases.
It's hard to deal with.
And then the cholera came.
And I've just told
you how that was hard.
So this picture, 1st of December
2010, when I left Haiti,
is a happy picture.
This is me after a
few beers, and I'm
flying away the next day.
And I haven't given up.
And I've done six months.
And yes, I stuck it to the end.
And I was recreating here--
you know sometimes
you have a few drinks,
and you think you're funny.
But I was recreating how I felt
at the end of these six months.
I felt smashed up and beaten up
and run over by an MSF pickup.
It was a hard six months.
And it was also at the end of
an entire year in the field
having been in Iraq before that.
So I had promised to
myself really actually
not-- to give up medicine.
I had promised myself
to give up medicine
at that point, which
was at the end of 2010.
And I tried.
But I came back.
MSF has this-- no matter
how difficult it is,
there are moments where
you just love it so much.
And I'll come on that shortly.
But I found-- you saw
that tent that was empty,
and I took the picture of the
doctor pushing the drip stand.
While we were doing
that, one of the patients
gave me this letter.
And he was a young man.
I don't think you can actually
quite read it there or not.
It says, I salute you
in the name of He,
who through his
death, gave us life,
Jesus Christ, dear, Dr. Javid.
So it's a very eloquently
written letter.
And he goes on to talk about
if you despise your neighbor,
it's a sin.
But blessed is he who cares
for others, who carries on.
And he says--
I'd forgotten who he was
at the time of reading,
but he was actually
a young man who
had a cardiac arrest,
respiratory arrest.
He had an acute asthma attack.
And I remember very clearly
being called into the ER
to try and help.
I had actually said don't
continue resuscitation,
because we didn't have
real intensive care.
We didn't have ventilators.
We didn't have oxygen.
But the staff appealed to me.
He's young.
I thought, OK, there's
one other treatment
we haven't tried here.
Let's do it.
And he had survived.
He had survived well
enough with brain capacity
to write this
beautiful letter to me
as a thank you to say
you didn't give up on me.
Thank you.
And I think right now--
I needed that.
Because I was
developing a sense--
over the years--
I came to read this
three years after I left
Haiti, a couple of years ago.
I had developed a sense that
everything I had done in Haiti
was failure.
Everyone I saw died.
It was difficult. I was blaming
myself for a lot of the deaths.
And I found it very hard
to deal with mentally.
But this guy reminded
me in a short, sharp way
with this letter, hey, you
know, you did OK sometimes.
So it's a very
important letter for me.
And it ends be blessed
by God forever.
A big thank you to
all the staff of MSF.
Because earlier on he says
thank you are the biggest
words in the human dictionary.
So I think it's such
a beautiful letter.
But I share that with
you just to say sometimes
it's too easy to fixate
on how you don't do well.
But others remind you
that you may have done OK.
That was one of my first
experiences with MSF,
but my last experience was
just last summer on the ship.
So despite having tried to
leave MSF and leave medicine
how many times, I'm still here.
I'm still coming back from war.
And it's worth it.
But what's Aquarius?
Aquarius is one of our
search and rescue vessels
on the Mediterranean.
It works just--
this doesn't point.
We work in this area
here, just north of Libya.
Because there are many,
many deaths in people
trying to cross the
Mediterranean towards Europe
from Libya.
And these are the
number of deaths
in that Search and Rescue
zone, the SAR, just there.
So people on the move
coming towards Libya,
smuggled or otherwise,
getting on to rubber dinghys
and trying to cross
the sea there.
So some 2,892 deaths
in that area in 2015.
And a good deal more
I'll show you shortly.
But who are these people?
They're many people
from failed states
coming from Somalia, Eritrea.
Eritrea-- there's lifelong
military conscription, unpaid.
It's a failed state.
You're a refugee by
definition if you
manage to leave that country
and you can claim asylum.
Sudan, also from West
Africa, so many flow
of migrants, people on the
move, coming from the horn,
coming from the west up
across the Sahara into Libya
and trying to get
into Italy there.
What this shows
is actually quite
how many people there are.
About 16% of all
those numbers that you
see arriving-- some 25,000
people a month in the summer
months arrive into Italy.
It's a huge number.
Some 16% of those are
children traveling alone
without their parents.
I had a patient who was a
13-year-old boy from Darfur.
He clearly had chicken pox.
That was why I was
seeing him on the ship.
Luckily we're-- I'll show you
how we rescue people shortly.
I had a 14-year-old traveling
from Mali, no parents.
In fact, his father was
in Paris he told me,
trying to reach him there.
But large numbers arriving in
Italy over the summer months.
And this is the number that died
in 2016 despite our efforts.
And you can see there
a good proportion
are women and children.
So it's not just young
men trying to arrive,
economic migrants or otherwise.
But how do you convert
this situation here,
which is usually what you're
faced with when you're floating
in that search and
rescue zone off Italy
in international waters,
how do you convert this
into safe bodies on our ship?
Because believe it or not,
this is a highly risky moment
right here, right now.
That's a highly risky
moment for a few reasons.
Usually the boats would
be fuller than that.
Often, both sides of
the boat will be full,
all along its circumference with
people dangling their legs over
and sitting for support.
So for me, when we see this,
we say, why is it not full?
Where have those people gone?
Why are these people--
what's going on with those
people just down there?
Are they unwell-- not
well enough to stand up?
It's tricky.
And if you're not careful with
the way you perform the rescue,
they panic, and you have
this type of situation.
And bodies in water is not cool.
13 died on this rescue.
112 survived.
They're given life jackets that
when they get wet soak water
and they sink by the
smugglers and the traffickers.
So it's unscrupulous
people getting these people
in these boats.
This is what you convert--
that first picture
to this picture.
This is a lovely, safe moment.
And this is what we're doing
on the scene now in MSF.
So the first boat--
I'm actually on the second
boat, if I could point,
which is the boat on the
right with the white helmet
on the middle person there.
But the first boat is
the boat on the left.
Now, if that dinghy
doesn't actually
try to drive itself away from
you when they first see you,
because they think you
might be Libyan coast guard,
who are now being trained and
paid by European governments
to push back these
people onto shore.
And we'll come on to why that's
a bad thing with Libya shortly.
So once we get to them, we use
the ship's sound system to say,
hey, you're safe.
We're MSF.
And we do it in French,
Arabic, and English,
the three languages mainly
of those countries you saw.
And Tigrinya is one
of the languages
of the horn of Africa.
So we get the
messages out there.
You're safe.
And this first boat, our dinghy,
our rib, arrives to the dinghy
and latches on and
doesn't leave them
until the last body
is off that ship.
And they arrive with the
first set of life jackets.
And then, I, with two
sea rescue people,
arrive on that second rib
with more life jackets.
Until everyone
has a life jacket,
we don't board or
take someone off.
Otherwise, it might
ensue a panic,
because they want
to be the off first.
All this time the first
rib, the rib on the left,
has someone on there in those
four languages just saying
stay calm.
Because otherwise, you'll
end up with this picture.
And you don't want that.
And here is another
way of looking that.
So there's Aquarius
in the background.
It might even go upwind
of you to block the wind,
to calm the waters.
It's actually amazing
how that bit does that.
And you come and go.
And you take the--
this is me, the back of
my white helmet there.
And you take the women off
first, or the children,
or anyone who looks sick.
And you can only fit
18 people on your rib.
So sometimes if it's 190,
200 people on these rubber
dinghies, you're
going back and forth,
back and forth that
distance to Aquarius.
So it can be time consuming.
And that's one boat.
If the weather has been
bad and they've not
been able to set off--
if the wind is coming on to the
shore, it's only a 25 cc motor.
200 people on a dinghy against
the waves, against the wind
are not going to get offshore.
So sometimes they're detained
on the shore for days waiting
for the weather to improve.
And then, if you
have a good day,
you'll have five, six, seven,
eight, nine of these boats,
these dinghies, to try and save.
But there are many ships
on the sea, all coordinated
by the Italian Coast Guard.
Two weekends ago,
8,300 people saved.
But make no mistake,
none of those people
would have reached Italy.
There is no way
that rubber dinghy--
it's a rubber dinghy--
can cross from Libya to Italy.
On our ship, it's a two day,
two night sail at steam.
There's no way.
So accusations by
politicians or otherwise
that we're a taxi
service, I mean,
there's no way these bodies
would reach the ship.
And they're people who
are destitute, no shoes,
just the clothing on their back.
Why they left their home?
Multitude of reasons.
What happened to them in Libya?
Dreadful situation.
I'll give you some examples.
But when we get
them on board, we
hand them a welcome pack,
a change of clothes.
Usually, they might
be skin infested,
because the detention
in Libya is so awful
that they have scabies.
They have skin infections.
So we take off all their
clothes and dispose.
Give them a fresh
pair of clothes.
Enough nutrition for the
first day, which is biscuits.
It's light and easy
to keep on a boat.
But the next day, we
give them curry and rice.
It's much nicer.
But on the first
day, we give them
soap, toothbrush,
toothpaste, pair of clothes,
a blanket, and a towel.
So this is them queuing.
Because it can be a bit of a
queue to hand that all out.
And you're only getting
18 back at a time anyway.
So it's a process.
It takes time.
And as soon as they get
on, you tell them this
is where you need to sleep.
Men this side.
Women inside.
You can drink water
from these blue boxes.
It's filtered water.
There are the showers.
You tell them where
we're going, what's
going to happen to
you when you arrive.
You'll meet the UNHCR.
The Red Cross is there.
You'll be safe.
But please don't wee
in the portaloos.
Because if it gets too full--
and if the Coast
Guard tell us to go
to mainland rather than Sicily,
it's another 24 hour sail.
400, 500 people on
board, two portaloos,
urine full, waves splash, feces,
people sleeping on the deck,
not very nice.
So don't wee in the portaloos.
It's like one of our things.
Please don't wee.
Anyway, so I'm getting--
so there's a lot of
logistics about it.
But once they're on there safe,
and they often just sleep.
They just sleep.
For the first two,
three, four hours, you
have this very eerie silence.
And you get the impression
that they've really,
really not had a good
night's sleep at least
for the last three, or
four, or five nights,
particularly if it
was bad weather.
So it's quite quiet
those first few hours.
But sometimes-- actually,
this is the women sleeping
in the shelter--
you get jubilation.
These women had just
changed their clothes.
They finally understood
what we were doing.
They hadn't quite
realized, potentially,
that we were the good guys.
And so broke into song.
It was beautiful.
Nigerians, the Christians,
singing a very beautiful
religious song.
But actually this
picture is also up here
to illustrate another thing
is that when you get groups
of young Nigerian
ladies like this
you know they're
being trafficked.
So they have fallen somehow or
have been even knowingly sold
by their family or someone
else into the sex slave trade.
And they are being
moved, very meticulously
in a planned fashion, from
Nigeria across the desert
into Libya, detained,
and moved on into Europe.
And the hotspots, the open
detention centers in Italy
where the UNHCR and the
Red Cross and everyone
receives these people when we
arrive in Italy, they're open.
And if you are 16, a minor,
14, the 13-year-old I
told you about, that's
a closed hotspot.
They can't get back out into
the continent of Europe,
because they're vulnerable.
They're children.
You look after them.
But the adults--
Italy receiving 25,000
people in the summer months
for the last three
years, each year.
They're doing a great
job in receiving them,
but that's a lot of people to
receive into your country who
have high needs.
So for them, it's a good thing
to have hotspots that are open.
Adults can get out into
the rest of the continent.
So the sex traffickers tell
their teenage girls to all
say they're
university, above 21.
And they'll all say they're 23.
And they're all
from the same city.
And they're all going
to do the same thing.
And you're just,
like, yeah, right.
And you're given these
indicators of vulnerability
by the authorities.
And we hand them over
to them on arrival
to try and just
take charge of them.
But amongst these women--
these women, there were 16.
Four had unwanted
pregnancies from very recent
sexual violations.
One of them had been
raped the night before.
And she said she was 23
when she first talked to us.
But on those two days,
they see that you're kind.
They get confident in
your good intentions.
And she actually said on
the second day, actually,
today's my 18th birthday.
And she started to
tell me the surprise
party she had the year before
by her friends in Nigeria.
How she wishes she
was still there.
What a different
birthday this is.
And it's a moment you
have with another human.
It's such an interaction
I'll always remember,
because there she was
just being honest.
What a rubbish situation I'm
finding myself in right now
compared to last year.
I wish this wasn't happening.
But then at least I take
away from that moment
that she felt comfortable
with what we were doing.
We gave her a moment of caring.
We gave her a moment to
say you're important to us.
Be warm.
Be safe.
Be here today.
Here's some food.
Well, I gave her
all the medical need
that you need after a rape.
And then, also, we give
psychosocial counseling.
And she are handed
over to our counselor
on land to carry on having
mental health follow up.
But a lot of cases are beaten.
So this guy was a Sudanese
professor, he told me.
He could speak
French and German.
And I tested him.
And he had been detained three
or four times over a few months
in Libya for money.
It's extortion.
They imprison you.
You pay money.
You get out.
It happened three
or four occasions.
On the last occasion
he said, I'm
not going to do this anymore.
They beat him.
And in beating him on
his feet with piping,
he had ended up with
abscesses and a broken foot.
So this is what I
was treating here.
This guy, a young electrician
man, he'd been sold.
Many reasons for how these
people end up in Libya.
But then also Libya is
so violent and broken now
with forced detention.
But he'd been sold
unknowingly to him.
He was bundled into a car.
He had been sold to erase a
debt he was told, transported
across the desert from
Nigeria through Niger,
stop over there, into Libya.
He was forced to work in an
armed gang stealing livestock
from other Libyans,
but he refused.
An armed African--
so the Libyans
were forcing these
guys, who they'd bought,
to then go and be armed robbers
to take the risk of being
shot by the Libyan police.
But it leads to--
you see what I'm trying to say.
So he refused to do that
and had been detained
in solitary confinement.
Had lost a lot of weight.
But they found out that
he was a good electrician.
He'd done them
favors in working.
And one guy he was lent
to-- so he's a possession.
He's a slave.
He was lent to another guy.
He did good work for him.
This guy took pity on
him and released him.
And so I said, well, why
didn't you go back to Nigeria?
How did you end up on
this boat, on this dinghy?
And he said, look at me.
I couldn't cross the desert.
I can't go all the
way back to Nigeria.
The sea was just there.
I thought I could get to Europe.
You don't think
about the logistics
of crossing the Sahara on
your feet or otherwise.
But these numbers-- these
people are managing them.
But he felt he didn't have
the strength to get back.
And again, when we get to Italy,
as I said, we arrive in port.
And we hand them over to the
authorities as I described.
They get safety but not
necessarily a ticket to stay.
Of course, some people,
their asylum is processed,
and they're sent home.
Some people it's processed,
and they're allowed to stay.
But this is the
lives disembarking.
And then, we go
out to sea again.
There's a big workload.
A lot of lives to save, as
I said, some 8,300 just two
weekends ago.
But some beautiful
sunsets out at sea.
Even here in Dubai,
I saw one yesterday.
That wasn't my really
last experience.
My last experience was that I
went back to Haiti in March,
just a couple of months ago.
I was lucky enough
to be able to go back
to help the teams in place to
organize a debate about how
to move forward.
It's how we organize ourselves.
It's part of our independence
to debate how we move forward
and open new projects.
And this is the team there.
But what I found is--
remember I said to you--
I showed you that
tented ward that I
was working in post-earthquake?
What I found was this.
This is one of our
three projects there.
This is a port-a-cabin hospital.
But nonetheless, this is
a 100-bed trauma unit.
This is the center of excellence
now in Haiti for trauma,
be it orthopedic or otherwise,
so car crashes, gunshots.
And it's an MSF hospital.
And I remember when I was
in Haiti we discussed,
what should we do as a legacy?
What are the biggest needs here?
And we identified this
is one of the things.
And here I was coming
back seven years later
to see, wow, we've gone
from that tented structure--
and that was my whole memory of
Haiti-- to something like this.
And it was so clean inside.
It was amazing.
So this is a really
positive thing for myself
to have found that MSF
is able to do there.
And also, I found that we have
opened up an obstetric hospital
with neonatal intensive care,
so newborns, and a sexual health
clinic, again, because we were
seeing so much sexual violence.
So this is one of the only
clinics in the country that
takes that into account,
doing psychological care,
physical care, and actually
social care empowering
the women to find a
means of earning money.
So that they don't
have to go back
to where the assault
occurred, which
is a new thing for MSF to do.
But I'm really
pleased to see it.
And I was really
surprised to find
that the clinic was in the house
that I'd lived in in Haiti.
So that picture
where I was run over
by the car, that was in
the driveway of our house,
[? Amina ?] Alpha Mike.
Our houses have
names, because you
need to tell the radio
station for safety that we're
going to x and y location.
So this is me at the entrance in
Alpha Mike just a few weeks ago
just shocked and surprised to
see that my old bedroom was now
the psychosocial
team headquarters.
And it's just like,
oh, wow, OK, it's
a really positive change
from that awful place
that I lived for six months
and that tented hospital
to things like this.
So I had a little bit
of closure and a bit
of very positive
ending for Haiti.
So I'm pleased to
report that back
rather than to be too
moody about everything
that I've said.
But one thing I take
away from the things
that I did in Haiti,
from that letter, from,
for example, what I've
told you on the ship,
is about these moments of
care that I'm afforded.
I'm so lucky to be able to doing
what I do with MSF to really
be able to--
the way I see it, there
are seven billion universes
on this planet.
We each live in
our own universe.
Do you ever look at
someone when they sneeze
and you think, oh, they've just
had a moment in their life.
No?
I don't know.
I do that.
I'm like, oh, that
guy just sneezed.
He's having a moment.
What MSF does for me
is I'm able to have
a moment with somebody else.
And that moment is when
they seek health care.
And I'm luckily able to provide
that health care through MSF.
But you get to spend a
moment with that person.
And it's their life.
It's their universe.
God knows where they've
come, where they're going,
what they're hoping to
do, what they've lost,
what they hope to gain.
Each of these people
I've talked about,
all those numbers,
sadly the dead ones,
they're each a person.
Just like you woke up today
and you go, oh, my back hurts.
Oh, I have to go to work.
Yes, it's Thursday.
Tomorrow is the weekend.
Each of those people
have those thoughts
every minute of every day.
So when you see numbers,
try to remember that.
We say, yes, we did 800,000
cesareans last month,
last year, of course,
the organization.
But that's a woman
having her child.
That's fantastic.
You know what I mean?
It's just so positive.
So I've been able to have
a positive ending with MSF
finally.
And of course, you guys, through
your collaboration with us
over so many years,
and most recently
what you actually did in this
office, are enabling that.
So it's fantastic.
So I'm really here to
say thank you for that.
And have shared that
experience with you.
I will play this
video as a thank you.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[MUFFLED CHATTER]
- [SPEAKING FRENCH]
[CHEERING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[HELICOPTER WHIRRING]
[END VIDEO]
DR. JAVID ABDELMONEIM: Yeah,
so real big thank you from MSF.
Thank you from me.
Thanks for listening.
And just a few
points of connection,
but I don't need to tell a
bunch of Google employees
how to connect on
social media with MSF.
I think you know.
But if you're interested,
MSF_Sea is the Twitter live.
You get a lot of information
there about the sea rescues.
MSF_field will be
from any other field.
Oh, is this not?
Gosh, you could hear
me though, yeah?
And MSF_field is
from any other field.
We call it the field when
you're on an assignment.
And the UAE twitter
is the Arabic one,
along with Instagram there.
But thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]